[Music]
today our Harith love CEO from tech
Ellucian and we're very excited to
explore how tech Ellucian uses anthos
but first love thanks for joining us can
you tell us a bit more about what tech
Ellucian does and what it's like to be a
Google cloud partner thank you Mark for
having me on the show deca Lucian is a
next-gen digital transformation company
and we're really proud to be at the
heart of the digital transformation
that's happening in the world right now
data is power right but when you have
too much data it can turn into noise and
paralyze the business what we do as a
company we leverage the power of cloud
specifically Google cloud any I tell
businesses go from reactive to proactive
and predictive as a Google cloud partner
we specialize in kubernetes helping
companies from strategy architecture
implementation and then manage services
the full life cycle of a kubernetes
experience and most recently we've been
very involved with anthos since a 28 in
April because we have a deep expertise
in the hybrid cloud space and we work
with various different hybrid cloud
technologies and we find those to be one
of the best and we're on a mission right
now to share the benefits of anthos with
the world yeah it's great to hear about
how tech Ellucian can help these
companies adopt like a very digital
strategy so can you tell us a bit more
about specifically how anthos helps
enable that yeah so just want to take a
moment look at what is anthos and this
is essentially kubernetes
and all of the bells and whistles around
kubernetes on the Google cloud being
packaged so that you can bring it to
your datacenter on Prem or any other
cloud and you can have a truly flexible
build once to pour anywhere experience
now playing kubernetes also some what
does that but anthos is enterprise-grade
allows you to do that very very
efficiently there are UI tools and
automation built into it for the
enterprise we were
with mostly we're seeing companies that
are heavily regulated in banking
healthcare gov and a little bit of telco
where they cannot move and modernize
their entire application directly to
public cloud for those reasons that I
mentioned so anthos is really a great
solution for them to start modernizing
in place or that cloud of choice and
then to be able to slowly as it proves
itself to be able to move some of the
workloads to the public cloud and anthos
allows them to do that in a very
efficient and very rapid manner yeah it
makes sense that the the value prop
there exists in being able to like you
said right once deploy in multiple
places especially as environments are
becoming both a combination of hybrid
and multi cloud the ability to scale it
out there is very valuable can you share
a little bit more about some of the
customers that you've worked with and
how anthers has kind of helped them sure
we're seeing a lot of traction working
with customers and healthcare finance
I'll take healthcare as an example let's
just SAS provider who's serving two
hospitals and other healthcare
institutions where the providing
software that ends up recording and
storing a lot of patient data that's
very sensitive data very highly
regulated so typically you know those
would run on pram or on data center but
now the cloud is very mature or very
secure and sometimes more secure than
your on-prem data center but there are a
lot of larger organizations in the
healthcare space that you a may not be
comfortable with running their patient
data on some of buddy else's public
cloud and shared with with other tenants
or due to regulations or whatever the
reason maybe they're not comfortable
with that
so the SAS provider by building and
modernizing the application base and
their data on an Akuma Nettie's anthers
based solution they're able to make a
choice they could serve some customers
on GCP where their application runs or
they could with the click of a button
deploy that same solution on prem to
their larger enterprise organizations
that want to run
Prem so that's one case studies similar
case studies we're seeing in finance but
the one that's very interesting a trend
that I've seen emerge is in the telco
sector as 5g becomes a reality we're
seeing an emergence of a lot of IOT
smart city type of solutions that's
generating a lot of data in real time
over 5g and the kind of data and compute
that they need requires an edge based
solution because even though the
throughput is faster going sending all
this data on the cloud and get a
decision back may not be fast enough in
this new world
so anthos actually has been a really
great solution to bring some of that
computer on the edge local level and and
the telcos are building solutions around
that and then for other services you
could go to the public cloud and the
true benefit of anthos in a deployment
like that it's very large-scale and
managing all of the nodes across across
let's say all the deployments out there
all the cities and public cloud can be
very very difficult without product like
and O's it's great to hear about where
anthos is actually solving these
problems and how technology is
continuing to increase and anthis is
helping make that manageable love thank
you so much for coming on and telling us
a bit more about it thank you more for
having me the illness shows pleasure
absolutely if you'd like to learn more
about tech Ellucian you can visit tech
Aleutian com
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more great episodes of stack jack
[Music]